les affrontements entre bandes rivales
dans la banlieue lyonnaise qui font
réagir aujourd'hui le syndicat de police
alliance il dénonce aussi la
banalisation de ces actes de violence
l'illustration de ce malaise dans la
cité des tarterêts à corbeil-essonnes en
région parisienne des émeutes qui ont
éclaté pendant cinq jours après
l'arrestation musclée d'un jeune lors
d'un rodéo urbain ce qui a mis le feu
aux poudres une vidéo montrant la mère
de ce jeune repoussé par le jet d'un
gars du gaz écrit mots d'un policier
alors qu'elle se dirigeait vers son fils
plaqué au sol nous sommes avait à la
rencontre de ces jeunes de cette cité
des tarterets une jeunesse qui appelle
au dialogue avec les politiques et la
police dont l'acteur omar soumaré place
donc à notre rendez-vous qu'en pensent
les français avec guillemard aussi ce
soir je suis dans le quartier des
tarterêts à corbeil-essonnes avec omar
soumaré acteurs et enfants du quartier
qui a ressenti la nécessité de témoigner
alors pourquoi est-ce que vous souhaitez
parler à ce micro aujourd'hui oui bien
sûr il est plus qu'important
d'aujourd'hui parler de de ce qui s'est
passé ces derniers jours dans mon
quartier ça c'est obligé un objet de
prendre la parole sur des choses qui ne
changent pas qui se compliquent hisser
truc non obligés de prendre la parole et
c'est ça aussi le fait que je prends la
parole aujourd'hui plus peut changer
quelque chose par la suite entre les
forces de l'ordre et les habitants de ce
quartier je serais sûrement l'un des
plus heureux qu'est ce que vous leur
dites aux forces de l'anp aujourd'hui je
vais leur dis tout simplement un moment
donné des d'essayer de se familiariser
avec avec les
avec les habitants de delhi où il
travaille on a deux trois trous ici qui
tourne régulièrement dans le quartier et
qui eux sont là que
pour la majorité du temps à faire les
gros bras et tout on est beaucoup dans
je suis le c'est moi qui décide et de
l'autre côté on ne me laisse pas faire
parler de ces jeunes qui quittent
parfois arrivent pas à communiquer avec
les forces de l'ordre pour quelles
raisons les jeunes ils ont du mal à
s'exprimer avec la police tout de suite
c'est le rapport de force ils ont pas le
temps de pouvoir parler avec eux eu
des forces de l'ordre profite de ça les
forces de l'ordre avaient en face d'eux
un mec qui leur répondre ça leur case du
tp est il venu de passer à autre chose
mais quand il tombe sur un abruti à ce
moment là ils sont là ils sont ils sont
mises en bête il embête il embête il je
sais où est le gamin il sait plus quoi
dire il va jusqu'à métrage je vois c'est
son seul moyen de défense
shu
elie saab de haut comment tu vois tu
perds tout qu'un type comme on a grandi
ici depuis thaler il ya
pas de
fécond et saison ici quant à 16 ans ici
ben écoute ça dépend si tu as été cité
quelque part acteurs ben j'sais pas été
acteur à 16 ans je pète un câble à 24
ans 25 ans donc c est à ça peut être
même de la chance maintenant quant à 16
ans ici soit
été assidus à l'école était quelqu'un
voilà qui c'est mais t'as pas le droit à
seize ans taparura de pas savoir ce que
tu veux faire mon avis parce que sinon
tu évites entraînée par les parlers
mauvaise ambiance par les mauvais délire
par les mauvaises fréquentations et ça
c'est une réalité qu'on peut pas qu'on
peut pas qu'on peut pas qu'on peut pas
négliger c'est quoi vous adolescents ici
à combien cela à l'époque on a eu la
chance de pouvoir aller faire du camping
d'idées voilà
des de la spéléo du
du kayak
d'être la plongée sous-marine on est là
on a eu beaucoup plus d'hommes et c'est
vrai que des fois j'ai pitié je me dis
vous voulez gazin vraiment pas eu
de chance je peux te montrer plusieurs
gamins qui eux ne ne connaissent rien de
alors mu corbeil ils connaissent granby
et rien d'autre et ça c'est une réalité
et on en veut aussi à un moment donné ou
au service jeunesse actuelle qui est lui
à délicate ils ont pris la décision de
délaisser cette génération une élection
présidentielle l'an prochain qu'est-ce
qui pourrait dire les candidats qui qui
vous convaincrais
moi franchement politique faut vraiment
pas n'importe quelle personne peu
importe la personne c'est quelqu'un qui
vient qui avaient été les hommes je veux
faire ça pour qu mais il faudrait qu'il
dise quoi il faudrait il va m'en tire
donc pourquoi ce positionnement et ça
sera bien là on est là pour moi le réel
problème le vrai problème c'est pas ça
enfin c'est ça ça ça reste un problème
est qu'on réglera peut-être jamais mais
le vrai problème aujourd'hui c'est les
personnes qui râlent qui cohabitent ici
ce qui cohabitent ici ce sont la police
et les jeunes
le premier grand pas c'est déjà dans un
premier temps que ces deux
ce que c'est d'eux que ces deux camps la
sent enfin s'entendre compliqué mais que
tout le monde met un peu de tout le
monde comme un peu le jeu